dans la chaleur infernale du haut
fourneau de zapporis style des hommes
sont à la manœuvre ici le minerai de fer
est transformé pour donner de l'acier la
fonte brute est produite 24 heures sur
en cas d'attaque impossible d'arrêter ce
cœur ardent et d'aller se mettre à
l'abri
quelqu'un doit être la coûte que coûte
pour tout contrôler
[Applaudissements]
nous devons avoir un minimum de
personnes qui restent ici et elles
doivent être correctement protégées
avant l'offensive russe la grande
échelle zapporis style comptait plus de
10000 employés 10% sont partis rejoindre
les rangs de l'armée aujourd'hui environ
5000 personnes travaillent toujours sur
le site les autres sont au chômage
technique
à cela s'ajoute le manque de matière
première l'usine à du s'adapter et
tourna 50% de sa capacité totale de
production
les exportations à l'étranger
majoritaires avant la guerre se
poursuivent mais non sans difficulté
malgré tout le personnel garde le moral
l'ambiance ici a toujours été
patriotique et elle est encore
maintenant 10% des hommes de mon équipe
ont rejoint l'armée donc ceux qui sont
restés doivent travailler encore plus
dur notre moral est excellent et nous
attendons tous la victoire avec
impatience
pour l'Ukraine maintenir à flot le
secteur métallurgique est un enjeu vital
avant la guerre il représentait 15% du
PIB du pays
un secteur qui malgré les difficultés
participent à l'effort de guerre
[Musique]
si nous devons parler de notre soutien à
l'armée
nous fournissons des gilets pare-balles
et des casques
un soldat sur 10 à un équipement de
protection du groupe médecine veste
nous avons également fourni environ 150
abris souterrains fortifiés
souterrains comme celui-ci qui peuvent
accueillir une quinzaine de personnes
ont pris place dans les tranchées une
protection essentielle pour les soldats
sur le terrain
un an après le début de la guerre la
scie produit est aussi important pour la
survie de l'Ukraine que le courage de
ses soldats sur le front une manière de
montrer une fois de plus la résilience
du pays